was ist nur mit diesem supermassereichen
schwarzen loch los ein us forschungsteam
hat jetzt den aktiven kern eines
schwarzen lochs genauer untersucht und
dabei eine äußerst mysteriöse entdeckung
gemacht das schwarze loch ist aktiv und
umgeben von einem ring aus schnellem gas
doch überraschenderweise kreisen die gas
ringe um dieses schwarze loch in zwei
entgegengesetzte richtungen und einen
wird bald ein spektakuläres schicksale
einem klick zum zweiten gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen schwarze löcher sind immer
wieder für mysteriöse phänomene gut erst
vor kurzem hatten wir hier bei pixum
science fiction über das geheimnisvolle
schauspiel im doppelsternsystem 404 zog
nie berichtet in einer entfernung von
7800 lichtjahren scheint hier ein
schwarzes loch völlig außer kontrolle
geraten zu sein
denn anders als es schwarze löcher
normalerweise tun feuer dieses
ungewöhnliche exemplar seine materie
strahlen nicht in dieselbe richtung
stattdessen eiern diese sogenannten jets
laufend hin und her und ändern ihre
richtung ursache für all das könnte nach
ansicht der expertinnen experten wohl
die supernova seien aus der das schwarze
loch hervorgegangen war
diese könnte dem schwarzen noch einen
stoß versetzt haben und es so zum
träumen gebracht haben seine achse
schwand durch den raum vergleichbar mit
einem kreisel
das führt dazu dass auch der jet seine
richtung verändert jetzt versetzt ein
weiteres schwarzes loch die astronomie
gemeinde ins staunen aufgespürt werden
konnte die seltsame entdeckung mit hilfe
der teleskope des atacama large
millimeter submillimeter array alma in
chile
damit hatte ein us forschungsteam die
spirale galaxie mit der bezeichnung ngc
1860 ins visier genommen und den aktiven
kern entdeckt der rund 47 millionen
lichtjahre entfernt ist im galaxien
zentrum befindet sich ein schwarzes loch
das wirklich erstaunliche eigenschaften
hat genau wie wir es von solchen
schwerkraft gegangen kennen ist auch
dieses exemplar umgeben von einem ring
aus schnellen kreisen gasen der
sogenannten akkretionsscheibe kennt ihr
wenn wir hier aber und zu reinschauen
einer der beiden gas ringe um dieses
schwarze loch rotiert in derselben
richtung wie die gesamte galaxie so
wenn man es in der fachwelt auch bisher
es handelt sich hierbei um den inneren
ring den die expertinnen experten auf
eine breite von etwa zwei bis vier
lichtjahren schätzen überraschend anders
dagegen der äußere ring der vier bis 22
lichtjahre breite ist er kreist nämlich
verkehrt herum um das schwarze loch er
rotiert somit also gegen die rotation
richtung der wirz galaxie ein echtes
spektakel denn solch eine ungewöhnliche
konfiguration ist den fachleuten bisher
noch nie untergekommen
zumindest nicht in den innenbereichen
von galaxien sondern wenn dann in
einigen außenbereichen dazu die
astronomen violett impliziere die an der
studie beteiligt waren das haben wir
nicht erwartet denn gas das in ein
schwarzes loch fällt würde normalerweise
nur in eine einzige richtung rotieren
irgendetwas muss krisenstrom gestört
haben denn es ist für einen solchen teil
der scheibe unmöglich völlig von allein
kürzlich falsch herum zu rotieren
dort wo solche gegen rotation bereits in
den außenbereichen einiger galaxien
beobachtet wurden konnten auch mögliche
störfaktoren identifiziert werden
demnach können nach ansicht der
fachleute kollisionen oder
wechselwirkungen zwischen zwei galaxien
dazu führen dass solche gegenläufige
rotation entstehen doch was genau führte
bei dem mysteriösen schwarzen loch zu
dem seltsamen phänomen der gegen
rotation womöglich ist der falsch rum
rotierende gas ring erst nachträglich am
schwarzen loch entstanden und zwar durch
materie die in geballter ladung an das
massemonster herangezogen wurde dazu
heißt es in der studie
es könnte sich um eine gaswolke aus der
wirz galaxie handeln oder um eine
eingefangene zwerggalaxien bislang ist
das allerdings eine vermutung fest aber
steht dass der gegen rotierende
außenring nicht mehr lange so existieren
wird die außergewöhnliche konfiguration
ist nach ansicht der fachleute nicht
dauerhaft stabil
der grund dafür die schwerkraft des
schwarzen loches die das material des
außen rings immer weiter nach innen
ziehen wird ein kollaps ist also
unausweichlich doch wann er genau
stattfinden wird ist nicht genau
abzuschätzen dazu jack belimo der an der
arbeit beteiligt war
das könnte schon nach einigen orbis oder
aber erst in einigen 100.000 jahren
passieren dann werden die gasströme
kollidieren und instabil werden und die
gesamte scheibe könnte
in einem strahlend ausbruch kollabieren
und vom schwarzen loch verschlungen
werden
doch die mysteriöse entdeckung sorgt für
weitere spannende erkenntnisse und zwar
zu dem bisher ungelösten frage wie und
warum manche schwarze löcher extrem
schnell anwachsen
möglicherweise liegt das an dem nun
entdeckten phänomen von zwei
gegensätzlich rotierenden gas ring dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie gegen
rotierende gas ströme sind instabil und
das bedeutet dass ihre materie schneller
ins schwarze loch fällt als bei einer
materie scheibe mit nur einer rotation
richtung wie sieht ein schwarzes loch
aus anklicken anschauen und breaking app
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran